hey house don't bros my name is Pippa
so I'm not gonna lie today I am
extremely hungover what's the worst
possible game that I could play while
being hungover and I remembered this
game it's called antichamber if you're
not familiar with this game it's a
complete [ __ ] mind fob
what better way than to just show it so
it's kind of like a puzzle game it's
telling me to jump thank you so much
game oh god I feel nauseous already this
is great oh [ __ ] okay
up or down we'll go up a choice may be
as simple as going left or right
alright well I guess I'll go left then
that [ __ ] is this what happens if I go
backwards sniff that your wish nurse
there we go yeah oh my god the hell our
balls doing here
what aah what just happened what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh god where am I
mom what what what what what I don't
understand understand I don't know where
I am I'm a little scared
Oh God oh it's a mace that's not so
amazing Wow this is why I'm number one
on YouTube
the punch ah stop
Oh God it never stops is it what some
choices leave us running around sir oh
my god yeah no I got that
aah oh my god oh my god this game makes
me sick
go forth my child go far
all right well this better be [ __ ]
worth it the reproach or I'm gonna be
seriously disappointed in you come on
Roberto
don't quit Rupert don't quit on me now
boy i Rupert went inside real bad right
back oh there it is that's the gun that
we need all right let's see if we can
get it in this episode I'm not sure well
there's a purple room even what Rupert
you [ __ ] Rupert don't leave me the end
so you finish over here interesting okay
what the [ __ ] is going on here what what
this is blowing my mind what is
oh my god I got an idea so we go here
right and then we jump down on that way
oh my god I'm genius oh god what
happened where am I
god damn [ __ ] how would you like if
you get stuck in this game how would you
even like look up where to go I don't
even know where I am I never I feel like
a little kid at Legoland like I just
don't know I don't know what's going on
man
what what am i doing what am i pushing
that oh if I could grab this I could use
it as an elevator cool but I don't have
the gun
what what ah okay we did it
we have the gun so now we can open doors
and [ __ ] look at that above above and I
know where to go already
so now what we can do is can take this
push that [ __ ] inside shoot there go
here shoot there oh my god look at that
face you look like yeah alright we're
one step closer I think I'm probably
what oh god did I just oh my I can't you
know what we're gonna have to end that
episode there I had a lot of fun playing
this game it's really cool and I think I
hope you boys enjoyed as well let me
know what you think believe it like if
you enjoy watching hits the sky remember
it today and I'll see you Bruce it's
always the next video always stay
awesome bros
they can